[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAY TSANG: All right.
Thanks, everyone,
for being here.
I only have about 20 minutes.
And that is what this
session is about.
In 20 minutes, this is what
I'm going to try to do--
create a brand new
application that has--
that's a Java based application
with Spring and Spring
Boot that has CRED
access to Datastore.
For this particular
case, I'm going
to add tracing,
distributed tracing,
so you can see who's
making the call to what.
I'm going to have
correlated logging so you
can see all the log messages.
I'm going to deploy it into
a production environment.
And I'm going to debug
it live in production.
And I'm going to try to do
that in about 20 minutes.
How many people think
this can be done?
Nobody.
Oh, thanks, yeah.
Thanks.
There are some people I
cannot disappoint today.
All right.
Very cool.
So let's do that right now.
How many Java
developers are here?
Anyone in Java?
Yeah, that's why you're here.
Fantastic.
That's awesome.
And how many people here
use Spring and Spring Boot?
Just about everyone.
All right.
Very cool.
So you probably know the drill.
You go to star.spring.io, where
you can go in and generate
a new application.
Actually, I'm going to
create one with Kotlin
today, because we
do actually have
pretty awesome Kotlin
support on GCP, because it's
all JVM languages.
We're going to use one of the
latest versions of Spring Boot,
going to package it
as a WAR file today.
I'm going to use Java 8.
Now, here's the important thing.
When you actually
add the capabilities
to your application,
what you can do
is to add the
different components.
So here I'm going
to say this is going
to be a web-based application
with a web RESTful endpoint.
I'm going to add this
very important thing
called GCP Support.
This is basically a project
that Google has created
in collaboration with Pivotal.
We add idiomatic integrations
with Spring and Spring Boot.
And that can actually
help you integrate
with many of the
Google Cloud Services,
including Datastore, Spanner,
Cloud SQL, Vision API, logging
and tracing, and
everything like that,
so that you can code your
application idiomatically
without actually
having to use our API.
You can use everything
through Spring.
So I'm going to go ahead
and generate this project
and see what happens here.
So I'm going to do devzone.
I'm going to unpack it.
Now, this is a new one so
I'm going to open this up.
And I don't really have
a backup here today.
So I'm going to see
how this works out.
And I have about 20 minutes.
I've got 17 minutes
now, and we will see.
So hopefully, you
can see the screen.
And this is a brand
new application.
And I have one class
here, which is in Kotlin.
And this where the
application will go.
So I'm going to go
like this a little bit.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is to add Datastore support.
So Datastore is
our NoSQL database.
It's document oriented
database you can use.
There is no schema.
So you can add whatever
key value pairs
that you want into the
properties of this.
And one of the
easiest things to do
is adding a dependency
here in Spring.
And we have Spring Data
Support for Datastore.
What that means is that you can
actually just create a POJO.
Or in this case, in Kotlin,
this will be a data class.
I'm going to call it
person, something like that.
Person.
I can't really spell today.
Oh, sorry.
Demo file already.
I'm going to say var with ID.
I'm going to have ID field.
That's a long.
And this can be null for now.
I'm going to do a name,
which is a string.
And it can also be null.
Now, what I can also do is to--
sorry.
With Kotlin, I need to use
the question mark here.
I'm going to use
Spring's annotation here.
I'm going to add it as
an ID with the ID field.
Sorry, ID right here.
Capital ID.
There you go.
And then to map it to
a Datastore entity,
all I need to do is to use
the Entity annotation here,
if I can find it somewhere.
Entity.
Sorry.
There you go.
I'm going to build
this in a second, OK?
So it should actually go ahead
and download my dependencies
and build everything for me with
the right annotations in place.
So I'm going to wait
for that to happen.
And it didn't.
So what happened here?
One second.
I think I may have missed one
thing here with the Datastore
stuff.
Let me just make
sure I have this.
And one fallback here is to
just go back to the console.
There is a little icon I
should have clicked which says,
do you actually want to
download the dependencies?
And I think I said no.
So that's a little
problem there.
I'm going to go ahead and
do a clean package here.
Whew.
So we're about five minutes in,
and we've got 15 minutes to go.
We'll see.
Oh, what's going on here?
Oh, there we go.
Unresolved entity,
of course, yeah.
So I do need to import
it into my thing.
Dadadada, dada, dada, dada.
Oh boy.
What happened here.
Google Store and dadadadada.
Hold on.
Let me just do one
more thing here.
Sorry.
All right.
So I'm going to try something
else very quickly here.
I'm going to get rid of this.
Because what happened
here is that when Maven,
we added this new dependency, I
needed to refresh this project
somehow.
So I think that in
here, somewhere,
there is a little Maven thing.
There we go.
I should probably reimport
it so that it actually
goes out and gets all my
dependencies downloaded
properly in this case, right?
So let me try this again.
Hopefully, this will come out.
Come out.
No.
All right.
So in that case, I'm just
going to go ahead and find this
somewhere.
Have to go ahead and find it.
So I'm going to go
ahead and import
org.springframework.cloud.gcp--
OK, that's there--
data-- that's good.
So we have datastore.core.
And I think we should have
a annotation here somewhere
that's actually of
the node of entity,
which I'm not seeing
for some reason.
Mapping.
There we go.
And I do remember where this is.
OK, good.
All right.
So now we have
the entity of map.
I'm going to go ahead and
create a CRUD service.
This is going to be
called a repository.
This is what we call a
DAO, a Data Access Object.
So with that, we can go
ahead and introduce Spring,
idiomatic way of doing it.
I'm going to call this
a person repository.
I'm going to go ahead and
extend the Datastore repository
interface.
So we have something
written here
called Datastore Repository.
And I'm going to give
it a type of the domain
object I'm going
to use, and also
the type of the
ID, which is long.
And that's pretty much it.
I'm going to go and expose this
onto the REST service as well.
So I'm going to use an
annotation here called
Repository REST Resource.
And that's all it takes, aside
from the little digress here
with the annotation
and the packages.
But this should be all it takes.
I'm going to go ahead
and compile this.
Hopefully, if
everything compiles.
And ultimately, I'm
going to run this.
How many people think
this will just work?
Now I kind of screwed
this up a little bit.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
So we'll see.
So I'm going to go ahead
and run this from here.
So I'm going to skip tests
because that's what I do.
I don't like to run tests.
I'm going to do
Spring Boot and run.
And what this
should be able to do
is to run this
application on port 8080.
And I should have an
endpoint called Persons.
And that will then
be able to allow
me to read what's in
Datastore and allow
me to do a post into
Datastore and store my data.
So everything is up and running
about 4 and 1/2 seconds right
here, which is not too bad.
I'm going to try something
really cool here.
I'm going to use
my IntelliJ IDE.
I'm going to try this thing
called New HTTP Request.
So I'm going to
say Test Requests.
And this is really cool.
So what I can do is to
do-- let me see here, GTRP.
So you can actually write
out your I/O here in the IDE.
I'm going to say persons.
I'm going to see
what's actually there.
I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
And we should be able to
see the get method here.
And we actually do have
some return values.
Thank you.
That's just the
first part of it.
But there's nothing here.
There's nothing here, right?
There's nothing here.
Why?
Because there's nothing
in my Datastore.
So to put something
here, I'm going to do a--
let me see here, post
with JSON right here.
So I'm going to do 8080.
I'm going to post it
to my Persons endpoint.
I'm going to zoom in
a little bit here.
And I'm going to post
maybe my name here.
So I'm going to say name is Ray.
Whew.
A lot of pressure in 20 minutes.
There is no room
for fixing things.
And OK.
I think that worked.
So over here, you can
see that I did the post.
Not only that, I got a URL
that actually pointed me
to the Datastore location.
That's the Datastore ID
that's auto generated.
And just to show you
this is actually real,
I do have to go to my
dashboard here to my Datastore.
And we should be able to see
this new entry that I just
created.
So if I go down to the kinds,
we have the Person kind.
And we should have
the entity here.
Sorry, let me go to the entity.
And that is a new data
entry that I just created.
And I should be able to
also go back to my IDE
and just show you what the
Persons endpoint now returns.
Now, rather than
having no records,
now I have one record in here.
Right?
Pretty cool.
So we got CRUD access.
We can do deletes.
We can do updates.
We can do all of these things.
Now of course, in a typical
microservices environment,
that is not enough.
You probably end up using the
Datastore for something else.
So for that matter,
I'm going to cheat here
a little bit with
a little shortcut.
I'm going to create
a Hello World
controller that is a REST
controller in Spring's terms.
And I'm going to have a
mapping here with a /hello
as the endpoint.
I'm going to be
able to say hello
with the name as a
request parameter.
And for this, what
I'm going to do
is to actually reuse
my repositories.
I'm going to say private
val person repository.
I'm going to inject
it into my controller.
And when somebody
says hello, I'm
going to use the repository
to also save these records.
I'm going to say save person.
Name is the name, and
something like that.
Now of course, that is
probably not enough.
You probably want to make
a call to another service.
I don't have time to
write another service
for that matter.
However, I can simulate one.
For that matter,
what I'm going to say
is I'm going to say
hello to everyone.
I'm going to say hello
to a few people--
myself, Mandy, one
of the first person
I worked with when I joined
Google Cloud, and Jisha, who
was one of the engineers
who worked on this project
called Spring Cloud GCP.
And I see Ludo in the
audience over there,
so I'm going to say
hello to Ludo as well.
And what this will do
is to basically make
a URL, a REST call, to
the Hello endpoint, going
through all of these names, and
say hello to each person, OK?
And in order for me to do
this, I do need to have,
in Spring's terms,
a REST template.
So I do need to have
a little being here
that allows me to make
this request a lot easier.
I'm going to go ahead and
use the interaction here.
I'm going to say private
val REST template.
So that is automatically
injected into my controller.
And finally, I'm going
to say hello to everyone.
Whew.
So let's give it a try.
I'm going to go ahead and
go back to my terminal.
Where's my terminal?
Right here.
I'm going to stop this,
rerun this, and do a--
skip test.
Maybe do a package
and Spring Boot run.
So now I just went from a CRUD
service to another service
where I can say hello to.
It's going to save
the data and also
something else that's going
to say hello to three or four
different people.
So let's see how this works out.
So everything started.
For this one, I think I'm going
to go to my console instead.
So I'm going to do
this rather, because I
like this view a little better.
So I'm going to go ahead and
say curl localhost 8080 hello.
And name is--
I think Tamao in the audience.
I'm going to say hello to
Tamao, who's from Weave.
And there we go.
So I can say hello to Tamao.
We can also see the
info log message here.
So now, let me
try to do the all.
Let me say, rather than
doing the curl localhost
with the hello, let me
just do all like that.
And I should be able to say
hello to four people now,
right?
And every time I
say hello, remember,
it's saved into my Datastore.
So for that matter,
if I come back here
and do a little
refresh, this is real.
None of this is fake.
None of this is
premade, all right?
So then what do we do?
If you're making a call
to another microservice,
in this kind of
architecture, all visibility
is very important.
What that means
is that you should
be able to see one
call to another.
Via HTTP or messaging
or whatever,
you should be able to see
how the messages are flowing.
To do that, we have a
really, really easy way
in Spring, and especially
with our integration.
We can actually use
Stackdriver Trace.
And all we need to do is, by
adding this one dependency,
we will automatically
hook into your application
and we know where
the request came in.
We know what headers
to propagate.
And now we can have
Trace propagated
to Stackdriver automatically.
Furthermore, what
I'm also going to do
is by adding a
logging dependency
here so that all
of the log messages
can actually go directly
into a Stackdriver Logging.
And something happens after
that really, really cool.
Now, because this is a demo--
so typically, when you call a
simple every single request,
you don't really trace
every single request.
But because this is a
demo, what we need to do
is to actually trace everything.
So for that matter, I'm going
to up the probability of a trace
to about 100%.
So here we go.
I'm going to say probability
of a trace is 100%.
I'm going to trace
100% of the requests.
Now finally, the last
thing I need to do
is to configure my logger.
To do that in Spring, they
use logback by default.
So I'm going to create a
new logback configuration.
And what I can do
here is to, of course,
add a logback configuration.
I do have one here
for API and console.
So what this one
does is that it's
going to log to the console so I
can see it on my local machine.
But I'm also going to send
the same log of messages
to Stackdriver Logging as well.
So I'm going to go ahead and
clear this and restart and run.
Now, we're about 15 minutes in.
We will see how this works out.
So I'm skipping tests.
Best practices ever for a demo.
And we'll see.
So-- oh.
Yeah, there's a little
error, but that's OK.
That's kind of expected.
That's expected error exception.
And we're going to fix that in
the future releases of this.
But we should be
able to see 8080.
I'm going to say hello.
Name is DevZone.
That's where we are right now.
And I'm going to say
hello to everyone as well.
So I'm going to say hello
curl localhost 8080/all.
Now, one thing that
you may have noticed
is that in the log
messages, not only
do we see the log,
the message itself.
What we also see
are these weird IDs.
These are Trace IDs.
Actually, the first part
of it is the Trace ID.
And the second part is
the [? Spring ?] ID.
And these IDs are automatically
captured by our Trace starter
and propagated to
the log messages.
What that also means is that,
if I go back to my Trace console
for Stackdriver
Trace, I should be
able to see that particular
request that just came through.
And I can probably see it here.
So I can see I
said hello to all.
I can see that I said hello
to Ray, Mandy, and Jisha,
and Ludo.
But here's the best part.
If you click on the little
thing called Show log.
You can see all the
log messages correlated
to each of the spans,
each of the Trace.
This is super, super
useful when you're
trying to debug
and figure out what
happened to your application
in a production environment.
Now, with the last
four minutes, I'm
going to go ahead and
deploy this into App Engine.
If you don't know App Engine,
it's the platform as a service.
In my mind, it is the
original serverless
because you can scale
out your application
to however many
instances you need.
You also scale back
in to zero when you
don't have any more requests.
So we have this tool
called the Cloud Code.
It used to be called GCP Tools.
But this is a plugin
you can add to your IDE.
I'm going to go ahead and
add App Engine support here.
And what this will do is to
add a little configuration
file for me.
So I can go ahead
and deploy my app.
All right.
So we added this thing
called the appengine-web.xml.
Now of course, with the newer
version of the App Engine,
we can run Java 11, as
well as the JAR file.
But just because
of the demo, I'm
going to go ahead and
up the instance size.
I'm going to do a
manual scaling just
so I know I definitely have
one instance running somewhere.
And then I'm going to use the
IDE to actually do the deploy.
So let me see if I
can get to IDE here.
All right.
So from the tool, I can go ahead
and configure my App Engine
deployment as well.
So I'm going to go ahead
and add in my configuration.
Now, this is all within the IDE.
This is all within
the Cloud Code IDE.
I'm going to go
ahead deploy my app
into my awesomely named
project called Wise Coyote.
And then I can give
it a version name.
I'm going to call it
the version of Dev Zone.
Maybe I promote it, maybe not.
Let's not promote it for now.
So I'm going to go
ahead and do this.
And I'm going to click Run.
And this will actually deploy
my application, all packaged up,
uploading only the
files that have
been changed into App Engine.
And we're going to provision
the computing instances for you
behind the scenes, the
computing instances of this app.
And we're also going to
give you an HTTPS endpoint.
And it will just be ready
to go and ready to be used.
And over here, you can see
that we also have the URL.
So this is a
devzone-dot-wise-coyote
whatever apps.com.
And then down here
is the default URL.
Oh.
I see.
I think I did make
a mistake here.
I do need to use the B4
instance rather than F4.
So I'm going to go ahead
and change that and do
the deployment again.
All right.
So it's going to go
through this motion again.
It's going to upload whatever
files I changed and go ahead
and provision this
environment for me.
This may take a little time,
probably about 20 minutes
or so.
No, I'm just kidding.
No.
It should probably
take a minute max.
But we will see what happened.
Oh look.
Because I already
uploaded the files
in the previous
failed deployment,
the second deployment,
it actually
knows I didn't change any files.
So it uploaded
zero files for me.
It's really, really intelligent
and smart like that.
So now my application
is up and running.
I should be able to
go ahead and see it.
Oh my goodness.
I have, like, one minute left.
And now we're just waiting for
the application to boot up.
And eventually, eventually we
can actually see it, right?
So this is actually running
in a production environment.
I can see the Persons endpoint.
I can see everything
that I just created.
And this is running
in App Engine in prod.
Now, here's the last
thing I want to show you.
Let's assume something
bad happened.
It happens to me all the
time when I'm live coding.
We can actually debug
this application live.
We can actually go to
Stackdriver Debugger.
And we should be able to find
my application here, which
is the Dev Zone version of it.
I can actually attach my
application, my source code
into this application.
Upload it.
And then have you ever wondered,
hey, what did that user enter?
What was the input
string or whatever?
If you want to find out,
with the proper permissions
and stuff, you can.
So what we can add is what
we call a snapshot point.
So I can add a little
snapshot point here.
This is not a breakpoint.
It would not stop the world.
It would just capture the
state of the application
as the code flows through it.
So to show you this
last thing, I'm
going to go ahead
and do it this way.
One second.
So I'm going to
go to my devzone.
I'm going to say
hello to someone.
Anyone?
I don't know.
I'm going to say hello
to Gloria, for example.
Now, watch the
application on the right.
Did you see it?
Was it too fast?
As soon as the application
went through that line of code,
we captured the state.
If we go into it, we can
see all the variables
that was in context of
that particular call.
I can also see all
of the code stack.
And this is a very, very
easy way to troubleshoot.
Now lastly, if you ever
forgot a log message,
this is what you do.
You go to log point,
and you can just
do what I like to
call binary debugging.
Why?
With log messages.
Because this is what people do.
You say, first of all,
I'm starting from here.
And then you say, well,
if everything works,
I should end here.
And if it doesn't get there,
you put something in the middle.
That's why it's called
binary debugging.
So at 1.5, maybe
something went wrong.
Now, every single time
that the application
goes through these lines
of code, these log messages
will also be added to
your log automatically
without you having to report.
So that's all the time I got.
And if you want to
see more of this,
you can join my session,
a full 50-minute session
on all of these things and
more, tomorrow at 2:00 PM.
All right, so thank you
so much for being here.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]